john as you probably saw on my twitter
this morning i'm quite fired up because
of the endless amount of
garbage that we are getting from
mainstream media and our political
establishment right now first off i want
to
credit and thank you for actually using
stats
and verified sources right there as you
explained what's going on
with policing and shooting that by the
way is very different
than jerry rivers which is geraldo
rivera's real name he is an
actor he is an actor that's all he is
and he is a man named jerry rivers who
plays a character named geraldo rivera
and you
punk and all that stuff this is nonsense
but this is what they
always do you confront them with facts
you show them the numbers how many white
people have been killed by cops how many
black people have been killed by cops
when it involved resisting arrest when
there was an outstanding warrant
etc etc and then what do they do they're
backed against the wall and then instead
of coming back with facts because
they know the facts are not on their
side next thing you know he's saying all
of these things you know these horrible
things
to dan bongino by the way dan bongino
who i know wants no sympathy whatsoever
but recently recovered from cancer thank
god and he's and he's he's an amazing
guy
but geraldo is just he's just gross i
mean this is what is wrong with pretty
much everything or geraldo sorry jerry
rivers
well you know the thing is too what he
does is what so many people on the left
do is he's saying
which is actually in that harvard study
that minorities have a 50 percent higher
chance of having an interaction with law
enforcement officers but it has nothing
to do with
the deadly uh encounters with law
enforcement which as we pointed out
there just in 2021 alone
50 white people have been killed by
police 20 or 20
uh uh 30 black men have been killed by
police let's talk about the other guys
john john very quickly could i just jump
in because you know on this dante right
situation
you know of course you're not going to
see a clear explanation of it on cnn or
msnbc or any of these other places
but the simple fact is he did resist
arrest he was being handcuffed and
jumped away that is not to excuse what
either was a mistake or gross negligence
negligence or or intentionally a
horrible move by that
26-year police officer right so that's
what that's what we can do david
what most people in the media cannot do
is say she clearly made a mistake and
she aired and she's being held
accountable for that but so
did dante wright in this situation when
he fled police and
before that because he had a warrant out
for his arrest i know you want to talk
to about the court packing issue
and and how extreme this is
i was saying before and we're going to
show some video of jerry nadler we're
not going to try
to try not to laugh when we see this um
because it's hard to take him seriously
these days
but we have to take this seriously
because they're talking about it now
like it's
in the abstract they're going to propose
a piece of legislation here nancy please
says
i'm not going to consider it but i was
just making a joke before too about
you know the seinfeld episode where
george talks about i'm like mennon
it's annoying at first and then over
time you have to like it because you
hear it so often that's what they do
with this stuff
court packing sounds ridiculous it would
never happen
and then all of a sudden it's serious
oh sorry i thought i thought we were
throwing to a clip
you're absolutely right this look during
the uh
presidential election joe biden refused
to answer the question whether he would
pack the courts it was obvious that this
was coming the progressives which are
running the show and biden is just a 78
year old
shell of a man who is not running
anything they are here to burn
everything down they are here to pack
the courts they are here to get rid of
the electoral college
they are here to make dc a 51st state
they are here in essence to open the
borders all of it
you name it whatever you can think of
that i can't even think of at the moment
they are here to do it and let's just be
clear of course this is a brazen
political move do you think if the court
had the makeup that they were happy with
that they would be adding justices to
the court this is
the most brazen assault on a branch of
government
by another branch of government in
modern times this in many ways is
exactly
what the founders were worried about
this is why we have
the separation of powers and we're about
to see we're about to see
do we really have three branches of
government that are separate
and independent from each other and are
supposed to have checks and balances or
is the executive branch in cahoots with
uh
the legislative branch about to
annihilate in essence the judicial
branch let's see
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch
full interviews on a variety of topics
watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell